bientôt monde c'est squeeze et oui
c'était tu as trop normal c'est rare et
n'est ce pas du coup c'est plus normal
aujourd'hui on se retrouve une nouvelle
fois sur l'aubaine werder de 15 mode
parce que c'est mon mode préféré il me
fait extrêmement rire un bon visionnage
c'est celui qu'a le meurtrier donc le
film est dire s avère j'en peux plus
beaux bijoux petits fans moi j'ai mon
petit on my hollande like boys les porte
monnaie on peut même se faire tuer
dangereux mais je suis encore innocents
sans armes si ce handicap il est caché
dans la salle de ben ali ou où j'ouvre
moi j'suis machine moi je m'en bats les
couilles
hu au nord du sikkim meurtrier heureux
d'accord mais qu'il est passé comme une
geisha
j'attends vie qui est arrivé à temps
j'ai bien fait comprendre aux cours est
moche non ouvrir la porte
je refuse je n'ai pas réussi jusqu'à
présent et et rangez votre crâne de
cette porte très bien je pars alors si
vous le cache pas venir te faire un
bisou non non non je vous ai gaspésia
c'est d'acheter la descente recule
recule recule on y lit moelleux du
bureau de l'internet
qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai interrompu votre petit et amendée
par le k way amical aux campings meka
geste et sur nos tâches tu viens direct
au québec a dû alors il fait toi à
chaque fois on tue pour rien en fait à
chaque fois jouer les grosses juliette
donné qu'il a créée voilà quoi l'avez
vous étiez bloqué vous pouvez pas vous
débloquez parce que vous n'avez pas de
couteau dont j'en ai conclu que c'était
ok les gars moi je suis la hoya aviva il
apparaît qu'en soit la polygamie
non moi je suis père la partie infinie
mais je suis le meurtrier qui n'arrive
pas tué je t'entends dit yannick un fait
d allumer temps mais pas dans les cartes
et vous d'un petit fédérer qui s'est dit
[ __ ] c'est vital gueule oh là là j'ai
tellement de talent comme beaucoup plus
tard je vais donner mon cv à mesrine tu
veux pas être encore plus loin de moi
merci merci tiens j'ai clair tu tapes ok
[ __ ] moi je suis innocent depuis
vingt-deux rhône quoi canine dit je te
le dis je suis là vas-y tire bye bye
qu'as tu à dire pour sa défense
méchoui à la défense de people elle est
exceptionnelle et il est grand temps dit
à personne
vous voyez a eu la tête de confiance et
la photo dont si j'enlève
oh [ __ ] même genre de la maison un
petit direct aux attentes et qui
s'accroche on fait un petit tango ou pas
aux [ __ ] mais j'en ai marre qua non
pour toi tu dit que je me fais
springhill moi je sors plus de la maison
si je prône dedans comme ça moi je dors
par les fenêtres ah non il y avait une
autre étape et comment est ce une
quatrième fois kg d'apple corps ou là et
qu'il aurait gelé mais celle là même
la banque est déjà lancé pour avoir
cette situation est vraiment temps du
coq
ces nouvelles idées de bloquer 1004 la
défense geiger year by by si tu me fais
confiance que tu qu'on se connaît tous
regardez le cas c'est bien dans l'ue
qu'un au dessus non mondiale dia espèce
de sourds la sépulture de kalinka qui
louche non mais vraiment moi je moi je
suis celui qui saute moi je suis celle
qui saute aux yeux c'est l'attend mais
calmes et cas la meilleure défense
possible pompe pour ma défense roulettes
clic non mais je sais bravo alors est ce
grave moi je propose des boîtes de nuit
un peu comme ça et bravo
moi je propose sa riche plus qu'un petit
était juste mais j'ai mes mains j'ai
écrit on va te tuer on va tuer jingle
c'est pas une auberge pas quoi what
quitte à tu et à toi je prends les gars
je prends le gars il est dans la maison
c'est luca s'est lui classé lui
une au feeling erding à la chanson i'm
here trélat les deux équipes mettaient
rookie le maire il le sort comme s'il
sortait j'ai pas poste de radio ainsi
chanté une baguette de pain
4 c'est faux c'est moi confiance
qui te dit je peux pas prendre les
gagnants bague qui ça que tu ais je suis
à côté du sujet voilà allez moi aussi et
voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sur le mode border et
c'était déjà la quatrième tu fais quoi
tu fais quoi arrête arrête sociaux tu
l'avais cherché
j'espère que ça vous aura plu si c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça
prend plusieurs coach à tout le monde
pis alors ça ça c'était bien de la bonne
grosse
le faire